我的朋友說
他沒抽菸
就不用擔心
肺癌了嗎
這個觀念
你可得要更新了
別以為沒抽菸就安全
現在很多肺癌患者
根本沒抽過一根菸
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友
胡醫師
這一集要和你分享
1.不只是咳嗽！5徵兆是肺求救
2.肺癌初期沒症狀 檢測手指1處
3.每天5分鐘  1動作強化肺部
4.肺阻塞恐成癌！2水果潤肺防阻塞
5.3物藏傷肺因子 你每天都在碰
不只是咳嗽！5徵兆是肺求救
美麗的太太
你知道嗎
在台灣每五十分鐘
就有一個人
因為肺癌而去世
他已經連續二十年來
都是癌症死亡原因的No.1
而且不只是在台灣
在全世界肺癌的死亡率
也是所有癌症當中最高的
為什麼得了肺癌的人
離死亡這麼近
因為它初期的症狀
是不明顯的
容易以為就是感冒
有接近75%的病患
他們到了第4期才發現
錯過了
黃金治療的時期
所以想要預防肺癌
最重要的就是
提早發現它的異常
要怎麼知道
有五個徵兆
咳嗽 氣喘 胸悶胸痛
體重減輕以及聲音沙啞
第一個徵兆 咳嗽
它是最常見的肺癌症狀
特別是長期咳嗽
痰裡面都還有血絲
這是肺在向你
發出警報了
中醫說肺主氣
通調水道的
如果肺氣受損了
那他的津液
就沒有辦法好好運作
如果你發現自己咳嗽
已經超過3週
還沒有好的話
就得注意小心
別再拖下去
趕快去做個檢查吧
第二個徵兆 氣喘
以前你健步如飛
現在爬到五樓就好喘
這就是肺氣不足了
肺氣不足
導致氣血運行就變差了
第三個徵兆  胸悶或胸痛
一般的感冒
不會讓你胸口悶痛
但如果呼吸的時候
覺得好壓迫
甚至隱隱作痛
那就得提高警覺了
第四個徵兆 體重減輕
你明明沒有減肥
卻莫名其妙的
竟然瘦了一大圈
別太高興
你以為是瘦了
可能是肺的異常代謝
或者是腫瘤已經在生長了
第五個徵兆 聲音沙啞
如果你持續沙啞
聲音變低沉
超過兩週就得小心了
你有3項以上的症狀
趕快去檢查
趕快去看醫生
可能是肺在跟你說
SOS SOS救命喔
肺癌初期沒症狀
檢測手指1處
我的朋友說
他沒抽菸
就不用擔心
肺癌了嗎
這個觀念
你可得要更新了
別以為沒抽菸就安全
現在很多肺癌患者
根本沒抽過一根菸
尤其是姐姐妹妹們
根據研究
得肺癌的女性
超過九成都沒有抽過菸
蛤 真的喔
不論你有沒有吸菸
都不要掉以輕心
肺癌早期
難發現明顯的症狀
但是有一個小細節
如果你發現
手指頭的前端這裡
它有點這樣子
比較稍微膨起來
而且呢
稍微有點像這樣子
彎著有點像湯匙這個樣子
叫做杵狀指
假如說
真的發生這樣的杵狀指的
這樣子的現象的話呢
可能肺部長期缺氧
或者是肺部的慢性疾病
或者是肺部的腫瘤
等等的相關現象
手指變腫
跟肺癌
有什麼關係
來我跟你說
在古希臘的時代啊
西方有一位
叫做醫學之父的
希波克拉底
他說手指的變形和
肺 心臟的病變
都是有關係的
像是肺癌 肺結核
慢性肺病
都可能出現
這種所謂的杵狀指
所以不要輕忽身體上
所有的小小的變化
就算不咳不喘
定期檢查健康
留意手指上的這個狀況
每天5分鐘  1動作打通肺經
想預防肺癌
除了遠離菸害
還有沒有方法能夠養肺
強化肺部的功能
可以用發聲的運動
來強化肺部
啊 發聲
是唱歌嗎
唱歌唱歌唱歌呢
不是啦
不是那個發聲啦
是發出一種聲音
嘶的方法
這個方法呢
是一種道家的發聲方法
它可以帶動肺部的氣流
增強肺的活量
讓肺泡彈性更棒
幫助吸入新鮮空氣
排出濁氣
那我們一起來做
坐著靠椅背
雙手放大腿
慢慢舉起雙手
吸氣
當手到頭頂的時候
雙手翻過來
天花板
接著呼氣
呼氣時
就發出嘶的聲音
感覺到胸部的擴張
嘴盡量地閉上
把聲音控制在體內
呼氣結束時
手放在大腿上
同時正常呼吸
這個動作每天可以做20次
什麼時間做呢
假如早上5點～7點
的時候來做那是最好
因為正好是卯時
卯時是補肺的時候
肺阻塞恐成癌
水梨和它潤肺防阻塞
美麗的太太 你知道嗎
什麼水果對肺很好
我猜猜看
應該是水梨
不愧是常常看我節目的人
不但水梨還有蘋果
根據胸腔這一個雜誌
它裡頭有個研究顯示
他說蘋果和梨裡面的多酚
有抗炎的作用
能夠清除體內的自由基
保護肺組織
減少肺部的發炎
這樣就能夠
預防肺的阻塞
那肺阻塞
不控制好
會變成肺癌嗎
沒錯
你這是很聰明的問題
研究顯示
慢性阻塞性肺病的患者
得到肺癌的風險
是一般人的兩倍
意思就是說
肺阻塞嚴重的話
甚至可能演變成癌症
而且死亡率也會升高
尤其現在的空氣
它的品質越來越差
所謂的PM2.5
空氣污染的細懸浮微粒
天天吸進肺裡面
就是默默的
在傷害咱們的肺
媽媽們
去市場買水果的時候
水梨蘋果
把它買起來
替全家養好肺
替全家買個保險
水梨的功效
有潤肺止咳
清熱化痰
特別適合咳嗽少痰
喉嚨乾燥
聲音沙啞的人
蘋果能夠補肺
增強免疫力
慢性咳嗽或氣喘的人吃了
是蠻好的喔
undefined
3大傷肺因子
你每天都在接觸
肺癌的風險
遠遠超過你的想像
有三個危險因子
藏在你的生活裡邊
煙霧 空污 香精
接觸多了
就可能悄悄的在傷你的肺
要怎麼樣預防這個肺癌呢
第一個
讓煙霧遠離你
首先當然是自己不要吸菸
而且呢
盡量的不去吸到二手菸
你知道嗎
二手菸可能比你
自己抽菸還毒
這樣子以後就自己抽菸吧
有研究顯示啊
婦女因為丈夫抽菸
罹患肺癌的機會
就是一般人的兩倍
為了你的太太
小孩的健康
有在抽菸的人啊
真的 菸癮來了
去外面抽
但是呢
你在外面抽
別人會吸到二手菸
所以最好是不要抽啦
比較好 對不對
聽懂了嗎
我美麗的太太說的喔
她就說叫你
最好是戒菸不要抽
不要去害到別人是不是
第二個 遠離空污
要選對時間和地點運動
運動能保護肺部
那什麼時間
運動比較好呢
趁著早上九點上班之前
車潮還沒有那麼多的時候
去運動
空氣品質
稍微比較好一點
早上沒時間運動怎麼辦
晚上在車潮比較少
的時間去運動
也是可以的啦
很多小女生啊
都喜歡在家
點那個香氛
心情感覺很舒服
這樣的時候
對身體有害嗎
沒錯
這是最後一個要注意的
傷肺的因子
美眉們啊
你是喜歡用香氛精油的人
要挑選成份
盡量的天然比較好
為什麼呢
許多合成的香精
人工的精油
或者是有化學成份的
那些香氛蠟燭
燃燒以後會產生
揮發性的有機化合物
長期的吸入啊
會增加致癌的風險
除了香氛和精油
香水 化妝品 蠟燭
也要挑選天然成份的
才不會傷害健康
室內香氛可以選擇使用
擴香石
或者是純植物的精油
這樣減少有害氣體的釋放
購買蠟燭的時候
可以選擇
蜂蠟 大豆蠟
這些天然材料
不含香精
對健康比較有保障
化妝品就選擇
品管嚴格的那種品牌
或者是有機的品牌
更安全
那我回家趕快卸妝
可以減少一些傷害
是喔 這樣子
能夠減少皮膚吸收
有害物質的機會
讓你更健康
喜歡這支影片的朋友
歡迎按影片下方的
「超級感謝」捐款贊助我們
你的支持
我們都有收到喔